- Okay, people it's March Madness
and we all know what that means.
(Kelly giggles)
Everyone,
it's when the NCAA men's
basketball tournament begins.
(Tricia laughing)
That's right.
And it is so fun.
And I actually fill this out every year
because literally all of my girlfriends
and my sister love sports ball.
I am the odd person out.
And so I just fill it out.
Now, they thought it would be funny
because people found
out how I fill mine out.
Cause I don't really
know any of these teams.
So, I thought it would
fun be to fill this out
and show you my reasonings;
Why I pick them.
Here we go.
If you want to, you could
download this on my Facebook page.
The Kelly Clarkson show Facebook page.
You can fill it out with me.
And maybe you know a lot of it.
Maybe you're like one
of my friends or sister.
I do like that you have a
Kelly Clarkson show pen,
ready to go, I do like that.
But I feel like blue;
I'm feeling like it's a lucky color.
So I'm gonna go blue.
So let's March Madness
people, let's get crazy.
Let's get crazy and fill this out.
Okay, this is so big, okay.
(upbeat music)
First up, obviously west region.
- [Tricia] Obviously.
- Obviously.
Gonzaga...
Now I did find this out.
So the numbers beside, if you don't know,
I did find this out;
Like the first time...
I think the second time,
I think my friends didn't
tell me the first time
until afterwards.
And they were like, you know
the numbers out beside them
are kind of where they rank.
And I was like,
information that would be helpful
when you're filling it out.
I did not know this.
So, now funny if I always choose Gonzaga,
cause I think it's a fun thing to say.
That's why I choose Gonzaga.
Gonzaga, Gonzaga,
- [Tricia] Gonzaga.
- Gonzaga?
- [Tricia] Zag, zag.
- Zag ,Gonzaga.
Okay, so I'm gonna go
with Gonzaga, Gonzaga.
There we go, Gonzaga.
Bye Georgia.
Okay, Boise, Memphis?
Now Memphis just has
some great solid music.
So, I'm gonna go Memphis.
Connecticut and New Mexico;
It looks like New Mexico Street,
but it's state, I get it.
But it's just, it looks,
let's see like street.
I don't know I'm gonna go...
Cause I'm doing this in new show
called American Song Contest;
And I just found out that Michael Bolton
is representing Connecticut.
I love some time love and tenderness.
So like I'm gonna go Connecticut,
because of Michael Bolton.
I'm getting wild with my writing, okay.
Arkansas and Vermont;
Even though Arkansas is
four and Vermont is 13.
I innately can't go for Arkansas.
Cause I dated a complete
from Arkansas woods.
So no, it's a no for me dog.
So, we're gonna go ahead and put Vermont,
and you know why?
Cause I feel like Vermont is
a beautiful place to go to.
Although Arkansas does have Devil's Den.
I used to backpack through there.
That's pretty nice.
Alabama, RUTG.
R U T G, Notre Dame, Ooh.
You know what?
I'm gonna go, Alabama.
I'm gonna go Alabama because
I don't know which team
is gonna be playing them.
So I feel like if they're
still having to decide
who's gonna play Alabama.
Like they might be the
already better team,
but good luck to the other ones.
Texas Tech or Montana?
Look, those are my roots and
the other one's my wings.
So, I'm...
I don't know where to go here.
Although I do like flying.
So, I'm gonna say Montana.
Although it's hard,
because Texas Tech, those are my roots.
Like not that school, but
like I just mean Texas.
And it is funny cause they're
ranked three and Montana's 14.
I like an underdog.
It's madness.
Michigan State or Davidson?
Here's where I'm just gonna go
with the better valued team.
Cause I don't know.
Michigan State get it.
Oh, Duke.
If I don't go for Duke,
my sister, and you, will hate me, Tricia.
So, I'm gonna go Duke.
And that's like the one
coach, I know coach K.
Is this is his last year?
Go coach K.
Oh I think I want him to win.
Baylor?
No.
- [Tricia] The defending
national championship--
- Tricia is a Baylor Bear.
So, I grew up near like
Baylor, not too far.
So I'm gonna...
Instead of Norfolk, I'm gonna go Baylor.
North Carolina or Marquette?
I gotta go North Carolina,
cause my family lives there.
So give it up NC.
Ooh, Saint Mary's or Wyoming or Indiana?
See, once again they can't
decide if it's Wyoming
or Indiana.
Like, I'm gonna go with Saint Mary's.
Also Patty Griffin has
a song with Marianna
and it's really good.
So, fine.
UCLA or Akron?
That's kind of hard,
cause my mom's from Ohio,
not from Akron though.
So, I have no loyalties I guess.
UCLA, let's do that.
Cause they're ranked number 4.
Texas or Virginia Tech?
This is where I come back to my roots.
Here we go.
♪ Texas. ♪
Purdue or Yale?
I feel like I'm gonna go Purdue,
cause I had a Miss Purdue;
She was a teacher of mine in
I think in the fifth grade;
Miss Purdue, she was...
No science, Miss Purdue was science.
Oh, she was so cool.
I just now remembered her,
she had a cute little bob.
I liked Miss Purdue.
We're gonna go Purdue.
That's what we're gonna do.
Okay, I don't know any Yales, so...
Murray?
Once again it looks like street.
Murray Street or San Francisco?
I don't even care that there are at 10
and the other one is seven.
I'm about to go on a
trip to San Francisco,
and I like San Francisco,
so I'm going San Fran.
You know why?
Cause it's fantastic.
Kentucky or St. Peter's?
Kentucky people, I feel like
make really good alcohol.
You've won me over, Kentucky.
and they like horses, right?
Like I like them.
Now that I have successfully
killed it at the west region,
we're gonna head on over to...
Oh, our west and east division region.
(both laugh)
Now we're gonna go to
the South and Midwest.
What happened to North?
(upbeat music)
Okay, Arizona or Wright
Street or Bryant or whatever?
♪ There is no Arizona ♪
That's a good song.
So that's why I'm choosing Arizona.
Seton Hall or TCU?
I feel like it's Seton.
I feel like I should pick TCU
cause I grew up near there,
but Seton Hall, Seton
Hall, tomato, tomato.
I feel like I'm gonna go with them,
cause it just sounds like fancy,
from like a novel I would read.
So, that's...
I'm gonna go there with Seton Hall.
Houston or UAB?
I already went with Alabama.
So we're gonna go Houston
cause like, why not?
Illinois or Chattanooga?
Here's the thing,
I know y'all want me to go to Illinois;
Cause they're like ranked number 4,
but Chattanooga is kind
of a fun thing to say.
Chattanooga.
Illinois's pretty cool though.
Chattanooga it is.
Well this is a weird word;
It literally ends in nooga.
(both laugh)
Okay, Colorado Street or state?
(all laugh)
Colorado State, is totally what I meant,
or Michigan?
I'm going Colorado.
I love Colorado, It's a great state.
Okay, Tennessee or Longwood?
(Kelly chuckles)
Longwood it is.
Ohio or Loyola?
I'm gonna go Ohio,
my mom's from Ohio.
John's from Ohio.
Get it legend.
- [Tricia] Bongo lives
in Virginia by the way.
- Villanova, Villanova.
That's fun to say, and they win.
Kansas...
Okay, Texas Southern or TAMC?
What does that mean?
They, can't decide again.
I'm going Kansas.
San Diego or Creighton?
Creighton, San Diego it
is, well it's vagina.
San Diego.
Iowa or Richmond?
I'm gonna go Iowa.
I mean...
Yeah, Richmond is what?
Their mascot is Spiders?
What's Iowa's mascot?
- [Tricia] Hawkeye.
- That's just cooler, that's an Avenger.
Iowa gets an Avenger, gets Hawkeye
and the other guy gets Spiders.
You've presented something interesting.
So what is Providence?
- [Tricia] Friars.
- Friars?
Like they fry food or like fry...
Okay, what about South Dakota?
Jack rabbits.
Sounds kind of fun.
I'm gonna go Providence,
because they're Friars, that's cool, okay.
Isn't LSU the dancers that
I just had on the show?
(Kelly sighs)
Get it, I like their dance.
I'm going LSU.
Wisconsin?
Love cheese.
Colgate?
I love brushing my teeth.
I wouldn't say I love cheese
more than brushing my teeth,
so, I'm gonna go Wisconsin.
USC or Miami?
I once had to do this horrible
movie that was shot in Miami.
So I'll never choose Miami.
So USC it is.
Auburn or Jacksonville Street?
My mom has Auburn hair naturally...
Jacksonville State or Auburn?
My mom has naturally Auburn hair;
I'm gonna go Auburn.
I'm gonna stick with my mom.
We're gonna think Auburn's gonna win here.
Ah, I'm gonna have to go cheese.
Wisconsin, love cheese.
Providence or Iowa?
They were Hawkeyes, weren't they, Iowa?
That's just cool, you're an Avenger.
Okay, I'm going Iowa.
♪ Iowa ♪
Kansas or San Diego?
I mean, I kind of feel
like I always go Kansas,
cause you know, somewhere
outta the rainbow.
That's where Dorothy...
I know, it didn't pan out
well, but I'm sticking to it.
Ohio or Villanova?
(Kelly sighs)
Sorry mom, but Villanova
is really fun to say.
Bye my mom and legend.
Longwood or Colorado?
I'm gonna go Colorado.
Oh yeah, they're ranked better anyway.
Chattanooga or Houston?
I'm gonna have to go
Houston, cause that's Texas.
There is no Arizona or Seton Hall?
Arizona.
Gonzaga or Memphis?
I just really like that name Gonzaga.
I'm gonna say Connecticut, connect-icut.
♪ Connect-icut ♪
That's how I learned to
spell it when I was kid.
That's how we all did.
Alabama or Montana?
Sounds like a song.
♪ Alabama or Montana ♪
I like Ruben Studdard, he's from Alabama.
You know what?
I'm gonna go Southern, Alabama.
Michigan or Duke?
Duke.
You're welcome, friends.
Ooh, Baylor or North Carolina?
This is where I get in trouble.
It's like the F's, friends and family.
Oh, I'm gonna go...
I mean they're defending champs.
Does that mean that they're
not gonna do good this time?
I'm gonna go Baylor.
Sorry, family.
Saint Mary's or UCLA?
I just feel like we should go holy.
Yeah, let's get saved.
Texas or Purdue?
It's interesting,
cause I had Miss Purdue
as a Texas teacher.
She was a teacher in Texas.
You know what?
I wish I'd have paid more attention,
and I apologize Miss Purdue.
So I'm gonna vote for you right now.
Cause I believe in Miss Purdue.
San Francisco or Kentucky?
I'm gonna go San Fran.
Oh, but they're like, whoa.
That's like 10 to two,
Great, you like ranked.
♪ Take a risk, breakaway ♪
I'm gonna go...
I'm still gonna go San Fran.
Watch me, look at this face,
I'm not even worried.
Okay, so from Purdue and San
Fran, I'm gonna go Purdue.
I'm just with her.
I'm with her all the way.
Ooh, you're not gonna like
this, but I'm going holy.
I'm going Saint Mary.
Have you heard that Mary song
that Patty Griffin song.
Oh, it's so good.
Alabama or Duke?
♪ I'm going Duke ♪
Gonzaga or Connecticut?
(audience laugh)
Gonzaga.
Gonzaga or Connect-icut.
Ooh, I stepped on my dress.
What?
I'm gonna go with the underdog,
I'm gonna go Connecticut.
Connect-icut, Arizona.
What's their mascot?
Wildcats.
What's Houston's mascot?
Please don't say something
obvious like a cowboy.
- [Tricia] Cougar.
- Oh, Cougar.
Oh, both cats.
But don't you wanna be wild?
I'm gonna go Arizona actually,
because they're Wildcats, that's cool.
Colorado State.
- [Tricia] Rams.
- Rams, who are winners here in LA.
So Villanova, what's theirs?
- [Tricia] Wildcat.
- Oh, I already have
Wildcat, sorry Villanova.
So...
♪ Colorado ♪
Kansas, what's there...
A Jayhawk?
That's a bird obviously
or something, okay.
You know what?
I think I'm gonna go Iowa.
What about Wisconsin?
Badgers?
What's Auburn?
- [Tricia] Tigers.
(Kelly awes in amazement)
- Auburn it is.
Tigers and Iowa?
I'm going Auburn.
Cause like one, my mom's
hair is Auburn naturally,
and two, they're tigers.
Colorado, Rams.
I just gonna go Wildcats,
♪ Arizona ♪
I'm gonna go Duke, coach K.
I'm going Purdue.
I'm with you, Miss Purdue.
Okay, so my final four
ended up being Duke,
love my sister and Tricia;
They love Duke.
Purdue, cause Miss Purdue,
she's great teacher.
Arizona, there is no Arizona.
"Raising Arizona" good film.
Love Arizona.
Auburn, my mom has Auburn hair naturally.
So, it just felt right.
(upbeat music)
Now between Wildcats and Tiger.
Tiger wins out.
So, Auburn it is.
Okay, Purdue or Duke?
How are they ranked again?
Wait, where's Duke?
And Purdue is three.
I mean so, I ain't gonna
pick pretty good people,
like to end with.
I'm really sorry,
Alyssa, that's my sister,
but I'm gonna go with Miss Purdue.
(audience laugh)
♪ Mrs Purdue ♪
But whatever, I go with my heart.
My final teams to for the win
are Mrs. Purdue or Purdue and Auburn.
So now it's between Mrs.
Purdue, science teacher.
I think it was just chemistry
that I'm thinking about...
Or Auburn.
Interestingly enough, both teachers.
Cause my mom had Auburn hair and like...
Ooh sorry coach K.
What's Purdue?
(speaks indistinctly)
What's their mascot?
The what?
- [Tricia] Boilermakers.
- Boilermakers?
- [Tricia] Check her still change this.
- Auburn it is.
Boilermakers?
What is the look of that?
What does that look like?
Auburn.
(Kelly imitates beeping sound)
Auburn's gonna win.
And I'm gonna say they're gonna win 82
because that's the year I was born.
What year are you born?
77.
Try one with 82 points, if you can.
When you're in the grand final.
- [Tricia] National championships.
- National Championships.
This is awesome.
Thank you Mrs. Purdue for playing part
in my past and future,
and my mom who has Auburn
hair, which is why...
And sorry my mom secrets out.
It's not really blonde.
(Kelly laughs)
My work here is done.
So let me know in the comments below
or if you enjoy doing this.
And if you don't know
anything about sports
it doesn't mean you can't have fun.
It doesn't mean you can't join in
with your sports ball people;
Cause I did.
And usually I don't fare well,
but I feel like Auburn is
gonna bring it on home.
Bring it home, Auburn, wherever you are.
Where's Auburn again.